[inaudible] welcome
to Google.
Thanks very much.
Yeah,
so a phenomenal,
uh,
it comes out on February 23rd,
um,
globally.
And so,
uh,
we're super excited.
Um,
so this is based on a novel.
and so by Jeff Vandermeer has a trilogy southern reach.
Um,
so I want to talk about a little bit about when was your first time when you
discovered the book or read the Book and,
uh,
what attracted you to it?
It was sent to me by,
I'm a producer.
I just worked with him on this movie x Makena and um,
uh,
I was in post production,
so editing and so on of x Makena he sent me a book and he said,
uh,
you should take a look at this.
And,
um,
I read it and uh,
and I sort of decided as I was reading it that I'd like to give it a try at
adapting it.
Um,
uh,
it had two particular things.
It's genuinely original as a book and that is unusual in itself because,
uh,
most stories that we encounter in literature and in cinema and in television
actually repeats of stories that we tell ourselves.
Again,
and again and again,
for whatever reason,
it's like a form of reassurance or a ritual that we need or enjoy or something.
And this wasn't like that.
It just stepped outside it completely.
So first off it was original and it also had a very,
very powerful,
strange atmosphere.
The,
the reading of the book is a little bit like having a dream and,
um,
uh,
that was also very unusual.
It presented a lot of issues in terms of how you adapt it.
I've worked on adaptations before,
uh,
where you have a certain kind of narrative that you're almost cutting and
pasting the narrative.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this,
I couldn't see how it would function like that,
but the thing that attracted me to it was true originality and this crazy,
dreamy,
trippy atmosphere.
Right.
And,
um,
you know,
you,
you wrote her novel,
the beach back in the 1990s,
and until that long time ago,
and it was a debit into a film.
So what was your experience like now,
kind of on the reverse?
So you had your book could dip it into a film and now you're adapting a book.
Uh,
well,
I don't know.
I mean
that was 20 something years ago.
It was a long time ago.
And I've been working in film.
I basically stopped writing books and I started writing films and working in
film.
Um,
over that period of time I'd done I think three adaptations,
uh,
as films that got made.
At any rate,
um,
one was never let me go.
Uh,
which was an adaptation of a book.
One was dread,
which was an adaptation of British comic strip character called judge dread from
a sort of anthology series called 2008 d.
And then there was this annihilation that was the third one.
And in each case it was different.
Never let me go.
Very almost slavish adaptation of the book,
um,
uh,
dread,
is like a set in a big Saifai world.
I work in a low budget arena.
I can't really do that stuff.
So I was faithful to the character.
It was an adaptation of the character.
And in this instance it was like an adaptation of the atmosphere,
I would say broadly as that's very broad.
What was it like?
It was really,
really hard.
I mean,
it was seriously difficult.
Um,
but,
uh,
that's okay.
That's,
um,
as the job.
What about Jeff Vandermeer?
So the,
you know,
the original author of the book,
Do what,
did you work with him?
Did you get any advice from him that you clear out the clear anything with him?
Or did he kind of say,
yeah,
I can do what you definitely are because,
because having,
having written novels years ago and had them adapted,
uh,
and really what I am as a writer,
but that when I think of what my job is,
I'd say I'm a writer.
And so I,
I feel an affinity with the writer of the book and a kind of duty,
uh,
to them.
And what I said to Jeff was,
I'm not going to,
I was upfront,
I said,
I'm not going to be able to do a beat by beat adaptation this cause I don't know
how to do it.
Somebody else might be able to do it,
but it's not me.
And so in a,
in a sense,
partly what I needed from Jeff was his blessing,
his permission.
And then I wrote a screenplay and I showed it to him.
That was it.
Yup.
And it's,
it's crazy cause it have,
how many of you guys read the book but people were there and called the book is
I just read it and I was spraying because the characters don't have names.
They're just go by counteracting that biologists have a psychologist.
Right.
And so,
um,
and do that in the film while I'm used to writing it.
Yeah.
You didn't character names,
especially when you don't need them.
But what I figured was,
um,
if you didn't have names,
because we use names when we're talking to each other and if you completely
avoided that in a film,
it might feel arch,
you know,
it might feel like an affectation.
And in a book,
it,
I think because it's such a sort of internal first person bucket,
it doesn't matter.
And it's actually kind of cool.
But in a film I didn't,
I didn't want it to feel mannered in that way,
so I just gave them names.
And so,
uh,
x mark in our,
um,
which you worked on before,
the subs,
your first directorial debut.
Um,
what did you take away or learn from that funnels director that you brought over
to this film and what was easier for us or nothing?
Nothing.
Fair enough.
Uh,
basically any way the job never changes.
I,
I find myself repeating this again and again,
but it's because of,
I think it's the way we perceive film,
which is as a pyramid structure.
And at the top of the pyramid is a director and it's,
it's just my personal experience of filmmaking.
Um,
uh,
I don't really like pyramid structures anyway.
I have to say they're not,
they're not my scene,
but,
um,
uh,
I would see it more like a mountain range,
a mountain range with a kind of parallax effect happening.
So sometimes one mountain feels more prevalent than another,
and then you shift your perspective and everything's different.
Um,
and,
uh,
that has always been the case at different times in the process in development
shooting postproduction the parallax is shifting.
That didn't change before x Makena after.
Um,
and,
and the truest way I can say it is that it's a collective.
Uh,
I work in a collective and it's a group of people.
Some of them I've worked with for 20 years.
Uh,
some people come in new and then they have to learn the vibe of how the
collective works together.
Um,
I'm not saying this is lip service,
it's literally true.
Uh,
uh,
it's,
it's something like a version of anarchy.
Uh,
it,
it's,
but it's not anarchy as chaos.
It's anarchy where you have a collective of autonomous bodies who are all
working towards the same goal.
And,
uh,
that,
that's the sort of methodology.
Um,
so I never sort of quote unquote coax a performance out of an actor.
The actor is responsible for their performance.
After we do a lineup,
a rehearsal and all the crew comes in to see what the blocking looks like.
Uh,
I then turned to the dop and I don't say put a camera here and put that lens on
it and move it like this.
I say,
how do you want to shoot it?
And that is the whole process the whole way through.
Wow.
And,
um,
so you talked about,
you know,
working with a lot of same people and,
and,
and kind of building up your crew.
You're without Oscar Isaac on x mocking out and he brought him back for this.
So what was um,
or it came back and gets bored.
What was,
when did you guys meet and what kind of,
why don't you to,
to reap cast again?
That's just a good partner.
We met in x Makena um,
trying to find the right cost and Oscar is a bunch of things.
Um,
you know,
part of what I'm saying,
part of what I just said before relies on likeminded people.
Okay.
So if you're not going to fit into that vibe,
it's not going to work.
Um,
and uh,
Oscar fits into that very naturally because he's a very self possessed actor.
Um,
he,
he thinks about it on his own.
He comes to a conclusion,
he arrives between takes,
he varies the takes.
Um,
he says,
I want to try it like this.
And then he tries it like that.
So it's partly that he's just flat out brilliant actor.
He's very self possessed.
He's also a good guy to have around.
He's very witty.
He's got a fantastic sense of humor.
He's kind of relaxed,
um,
like what's not to like,
yeah.
Now easily.
He's phenomenal.
Our next on you have
an incredible cast with Natalie Portman and who plays lead junior Rodriguez,
Tessa Thompson,
um,
Jennifer,
Jason Leigh,
and so brilliant.
Yeah,
no,
and it's,
it's a phenomenal,
a phenomenal cast.
So when you're casting your lead and you're kind of looking at the characters in
the book and then you're trying to adapt that to,
to what your vision is,
where,
how did you land on,
especially with Natalie being the lead,
how'd you find her and,
and what qualities did she bring to that where you're like,
this is,
this is my Lena Wah Wah Notley has as an actor is,
uh,
she's got these two concurrent things going on at the same time.
One of them is an enormous amount of poise.
Um,
she's,
she's kind of,
she has a powerful presence in her behavior,
in the way she looks in this sort of aura around her and all that kind of stuff.
I'm talking about primarily talking about in terms of performance,
um,
because obviously that's the thing that is on the screen and that's what you're
looking for.
But she also has something else,
uh,
which is she has the ability to demonstrate damage between the cracks.
And so as well as having all of these actually rather intimidating features,
uh,
there's something she can tap into which is broken and,
um,
explosive,
uh,
and,
and kind of wild.
Um,
and so there's a sort of subversion inside her and that made her exactly right
for this particular character.
Yeah.
And she's absolutely been with the entire cast is just so well,
well Castin and,
and so well chosen and phenomenal.
And the movie is just,
it's crazy where we talked about this a little confident where it's just,
it's really weird.
It's a mind numbing thing and it's phenomenal.
Like it's so,
so,
so freaking good.
Cooler.
Um,
where I was,
was there any kind of know,
but what,
was there any kind of like,
no,
it's,
it's smell,
but like was there any inspiration in terms of the store,
cause it did change from the novel.
Where did you kind of pull from in terms of what it,
was it the story you were arresting him for a while or did it just kind of
evolve as you are right now?
There was two things.
I think always when I'm working there's something that's obsessing me for some
reason or another.
Uh,
and in this case it was about self destruction.
Um,
I,
I had this kind of thing that I'd become,
uh,
aware of,
or I believe I'd become aware of which was that,
um,
uh,
everyone I know,
and I would speculate,
everybody in the room at the moment is self destructive.
And,
um,
you meet some people and their self destruction is very apparent.
They almost offer it up to you.
Uh,
they're an alcoholic.
They're a heroin addict.
They keep,
uh,
committing crimes.
They're recidivist or whatever it,
and you can see it.
It's,
it's sort of demonstrated.
And then you also meet people who are very confident,
comfortable in their own skin,
they've got a great job,
they earn a lot of money,
they have a fantastic family and you feel always slightly on the back foot
because those people are intimidating.
And you also feel that they have cracked life in some kind of way.
They've cracked it.
And then if you become very close to one of those people,
you discover odd fishes here and there and you discover very strange bits of
meaningless self,
destructive behavior.
And it was the meaninglessness of the self destructive behavior that I found
interesting.
And,
uh,
people are the,
you know,
even the sort of supernaturally,
uh,
pre possessed person is,
is sort of dismantling their job or they're dismantling of friendship or they're
dismantling their marriage.
And,
uh,
and,
and so that became the kind of fixation that was overlaid onto this film.
It is basically a film about self destruction and it has a kind of thesis within
a about why we do that.
Um,
and uh,
and the,
the various forms in which it takes,
I suppose.
Um,
and then in terms of overlaying that onto Jeff's really beautiful novel,
uh,
which is about another kind of destruction,
more eco the planet.
Um,
uh,
I thought reading this book is like a dream.
So,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to adapt to it like a dream.
I'm not going to reread the book,
I'm going to adapt it for my memory of the book.
And,
uh,
and in a way that was what Jeff gave me permission to do.
So in some places it will correlate very closely in another places it won't,
um,
you tap into that feeling that you got from the book versus just how it's a
dream response to a dream book kind of.
And uh,
and it,
and it's an interesting thing as well because then it becomes about the nature
of memory,
I think to an extent as well.
I years and years ago I was watching some TV show and there was a cop talking
about eye witnesses and he said,
I witnessed as a useless,
like,
forget about everyone thinks an eye witnesses the best thing you can have in
solving a crime.
But it's like the worst and,
and what you need is empirical evidence,
fingerprints and DNA and stuff like that.
And he was saying someone runs into a restaurant and there's a violent crime and
someone's killed.
And one eye witness will say he had a gun shot five times and another one will
say shot once.
Another one would say there wasn't a gun,
it was a knife.
And He,
you,
you can't really rely on memory.
And actually in my life I've often observed that's true.
Um,
and uh,
so it was sort of making that application of that,
that thing about subjectivity or suppose to,
uh,
to the story.
And so it's,
it's a
beautiful film,
beautifully shot.
And the set design steps.
I want to talk a little bit about that in terms of where was it shot?
How did you expand upon using practical effects and practical set design versus
Cgi,
uh,
were shot.
So,
so one of the things about this movie was to make everything off,
you know,
kind of,
it starts in a suburban setting and it ends in a psychedelic setting.
This is suburbia to Psychedelia story.
And,
uh,
so the awfulness,
how you get the quality of awfulness was,
was an important part of it.
And,
um,
uh,
so what we did was we,
rather than shoot it,
it's notionally set somewhere on a coastal part of North America,
Florida Ish.
Right.
Um,
and we could have shown it in northern Florida,
we could have showed it in Louisiana.
He's got a good tax break and all that kind of thing.
Um,
but we ended up shooting it in England,
just outside London,
and we dressed an English forest to look kind of like a distorted version of a
North American bit of southern,
southern,
North American coastline.
And in the hope it would give us some of the otherness we were looking for a
rightness and wrongness.
And I think I,
you know,
I kind of think it did.
Yeah.
No,
it's,
it's great.
Um,
when you are,
um,
working with sings like that and stuff,
because it's a very complicated film.
There's a lot going on.
There are monsters.
So I guess I could call her animals.
Yeah.
Evoke a animals.
And,
um,
so when you're working with that,
was there any,
what was the most,
I guess,
difficult scene that you had to work with or get right?
Uh,
or challenging?
The film got progressively more difficult because there's a kind of contract
that is in a way made with the audience at the beginning of the film,
which is that this is going to end in a strange place.
And Creating Strangeness in a Film Is Complicated.
Um,
partly because like Jeff's normally it has to be original.
and so we had to find out where we sourced that strangeness and the,
that that was part of the question.
And also strangeness itself has a kind of diminishing return.
So if you start a story strange and end it strange,
by the time you get to the end,
you're kind of a climatized to the strangeness and it's actually lost the
quality that you specifically wanted at the end.
So,
uh,
hence suburbia,
starting in a suburban setting and,
and progressively giving a film a nudge forward into a more and more hopefully
earned,
uh,
hallucinated a hallucinogenic kind of state.
Okay.
Um,
and we're going to go into court just a few minutes.
If you guys want this,
there's a Mike there.
Do you want to stand there and just make sure you flip it on?
Um,
but uh,
when you are,
um,
when you're obviously crept in the film and you're shooting it and then again,
editorial,
was there anything that you have to cut for time or for pacing that you wished
you could've kept in it or was everything was in there
that you want to do?
The part of the job is making sure that the end cap,
the end thing is the thing that the collective was working towards and being
respectful of that.
And uh,
that can involve a conflict sometimes,
but um,
uh,
but you got to stay true to the thing that you intended to do and um,
so nothing is on the cutting room floor that should have been in there and
nothing's in there that shouldn't be in there as a collective.
We,
we are judged on the final product.
So you better respect the final products and do it the way you meant it.
Right.
And were there any directors or films kind of when you were growing up that
helped kind of inspire you to become the director that you are one of the
reasons that you are as well
loads?
Yeah.
I mean,
um,
uh,
the first film I ever made a really strong impact on me was probably apocalypse
now.
Um,
uh,
I also love the first alien movie.
I think it's just an incredibly beautifully constructed,
intelligent bit of filmmaking and,
and subversive as well.
I think I like films that are subversive,
you know,
I like things that work within Georgia and then fuck with a jeweler in some way.
Yeah,
it's great.
Um,
you mentioned kind of the anarchic,
uh,
environment that you work in when you make your films.
Does that bleed into when you write or is writing totally solo.
And then my second question is,
now that you've done writing,
directing and both,
do you have a preference?
Uh,
no preference.
I think it's the same job basically.
And in terms of the solo aspect,
yeah.
You start writing on your own.
You do.
Uh,
one of the first surprise is I had with writing,
actually I've been doing it about 25 years.
And one of the first surprises,
this sound like a stupid thing to say,
but I realized you never get promoted.
Like there's no ladder.
You move up because it always begins with a blank page.
And uh,
that was sort of a shock bizarrely.
You know,
I thought something would happen.
Um,
but it doesn't.
so,
so you,
you start on your own but it,
then it then stops and it becomes part of the collective for various reasons.
One is that the script is effectively parceled out to different departments,
production,
design and wardrobe and VFX and special effects and all that kind of stuff.
And all of those people are bringing their interpretation to it.
Also,
what happens is actors get involved and you are not the possessor of the
character.
And he more,
when the actor becomes involved,
it's actually their character.
And what I've found with actors,
and this is true across the board,
hence the collective right,
is that they make it better.
They elevate it.
They,
they do things you just didn't think of.
And the first movie I ever worked on the phone on the first one I ever wrote was
a Zombie movie 28 days later.
And there was an actor in it,
Brendan Gleeson,
and when he was doing the lines,
I kept hearing things that I had not intended or thought of or known about.
And I realized right from the get go what,
what a good actor can do.
You know?
And so,
uh,
so yes,
it begins on your own,
but then really becomes like everything else in the film,
which is part of a big conversation amongst the autonomous units.
Did you
go into writing wanting to be a director or did you just,
did that just come in my cabin like he just happened?
Yeah,
I,
I didn't,
I didn't start writing,
wanting to be a writer.
Like none of it was intentional.
Um,
uh,
I was a backpacker.
I started writing about backpacking that turned into a book,
the book or made into a film.
I thought,
hang on a minute.
You don't have to sit in a room on your own the whole time,
you can be with a bunch of other people that I was working on films.
And then,
uh,
gradually,
I,
in a funny way,
I actually became a director to sort of get rid of the director in truth to just
for the absence of the director.
Uh,
I've noticed personally that I tend to enjoy films and TV shows where the writer
and director are one and the same.
And so I'm curious your perspective when you fill both roles,
what,
what advantage does that give you or maybe inversely if you're only doing one of
the two,
what handicaps and why is it that a powerful combination when your mind?
Um,
I think,
I mean immediately my brain starts filling with directors who are terrific.
You don't,
right.
But I take your point and um,
uh,
I think what it is is that in the end,
probably the most useful thing that you can do on set is to be able to answer a
question.
So if somebody is puzzled over why this bit of motivation is happening or why
this thing should look like that or whatever it happens to be,
which happens to all of us,
right?
You are confused about why you're doing the thing you were doing.
And if you are in the position of writing and directing,
you're in a very good position to offer your opinion and informed opinion.
Now that doesn't have to get observed,
but it does mean you can say something from a position of some,
uh,
personal knowledge.
And,
uh,
and I think that in,
in,
and amongst the talents,
it's useful to have someone as a sounding board.
And,
and I think that often my job is on a day to day level is being someone you can
have a conversation with.
It may be that,
but,
but then I'll tell you a lot,
wow.
Just,
there's no cookie cutter.
Right?
And one thing I've learned is that you never know how a film is made.
Whatever the credit say at the end.
You never know how a film is made unless you worked on that film.
And I'm the processes with one group and not the process is with another and so
a different ball game with other people.
That's just me.
Hi.
I'm going to bring it back to an isolation for a second because um,
I was introduced to annihilation and the southern reach trilogy via the trailer
and the teaser when I saw it and I just was blown away and was like,
what is this thing?
And so I read all the books very sequentially and there's a little bit of
unresolved ness,
not only about the first one but about all of them in general.
And I love that you said the dream state and then your dream of that is what I
was drawn into.
And I'm curious to know how the other to either play into this or don't at all.
It's kind of,
they don't touch it in any way
that they really don't.
I mean it's partly because Jeff was writing the trilogy.
He was still actually writing it while I was writing the screenplay for the
first.
But it's not,
it's not just that,
I mean that's just sort of factually the state of affairs.
But it's also because I,
I don't want it to work on,
uh,
franchises.
Um,
I,
I have no judgment for people who do it.
It's a completely personal position and it,
and it doesn't stem from anything about the nature of franchises or sequels or
anything like that.
It's because at the end of a three year process,
I know of myself already.
I will not want to work on it again.
That's it.
Thank you.
Alex,
you touched on this a little bit about the idea of having this thesis,
uh,
in your,
in your films,
especially in this one that you,
you touched on.
Um,
how early does that come out in your writing process?
Do you start with a thesis or did you sometimes discover it during the process?
And if you could just maybe take us through the beginnings of a,
of a story for your house,
how you start with it starts with a thesis.
Um,
it will be some particular thing that I've started to get obsessed with and I'm
thinking about it in a repetitive,
compulsive way.
It's,
it's not really an intellectual process.
It's a compulsive process.
And,
uh,
um,
in,
in the case of annihilation,
it was,
uh,
self destruction and uh,
this,
the odd qualities of self destruction and the odd places in which you find it.
And in the thing I'm working on at the moment,
uh,
it was a principle called determinism,
a sort of product of living in a physical universe of cause and effect and,
uh,
some of the implications of that to do with freewill and,
un Un what potentially one could predict of actions and that kind of thing.
And so I get interested in that.
I start to read about it,
I start to,
uh,
I start to obsess and then at some point,
not intentionally a narrative arrives that inevitably is dovetailed to the thing
I'm obsessed about at that moment.
And it's another reason why I don't work on sequels because,
because I want to be interested in something else and I will be interested in
something else because I've gotten a limited capacity to be too,
to know much about anything,
right.
At a certain point.
So I feel,
okay,
I've learned this up to my ability or I've explored out to my ability what's
next?
Kind of,
it's not quite as present as that,
but it's,
you know,
more or less.
Last question.
Um,
nowadays I know that original content,
it's so hard to come by.
And so,
uh,
for you being a writer and coming up with original ideas and stuff like that,
are you constantly thinking about,
you know,
what the next original idea is going to be?
Or is it just one day something pops into your head and you just,
you know,
go for it?
Well,
in all honesty,
I'm not sure.
I think this is one of the reasons I was interested in Jeff's book is I'm not
sure I do come up with original ideas.
I'm not sure that's what I do.
I think I often work with an existing ideas and sometimes then use the ability
to subvert them or play around with them.
Um,
uh,
so no,
I'm not thinking about what is the next original idea.
I wouldn't be able to think like that even if I wanted to.
Uh,
if I think back of the things I've written,
a spec scripts,
so say a film like 28 days later or a film like x Makena I can point you towards
a lot of Zombie movies and I can point you towards a lot of movies that are
concerned with artificial intelligence or the nature of sentience or
objectification or whatever.
The,
the concern is within the thing.
In a way,
that's partly why I found the book annihilation so interesting is because maybe
I lack the capacity to do that and Jeff has done that and that,
that's uh,
that's a,
that's like a honey to be no nectar.
They make honey.
So some sort of appropriate analogy
and a to wrap up,
uh,
as a,
a screen writer and novelist and director,
what piece of advice have you received that has been this kind of stuck with you
over the years?
Um,
the only,
the first bit of advice that came into my head was my dad when I was a kid
saying,
you think someone's going to hit you hit them first.
It was more just the general life lesson.
Fair enough.
I did doesn't apply.
It's just the only bit of advice.
I cannot top that.
So thank you so much for being here.
Go Watch it.
It's phenomenal.